por qué
[Música]
gracias por continuar con nosotros y
bienvenidos a 5 minutos con el pasado
lunes 22 de febrero el embajador de
guatemala en italia asumió la
presidencia de la junta ejecutiva del
programa mundial de alimentos un
organismo creado por las naciones unidas
para luchar contra el hambre y la
desnutrición en el mundo embajador luis
carranza muchas gracias por estar con
nosotros aquí en el centro de roma
muchas gracias por la invitación un
placer su nombramiento es un evento
importante considerando que el programa
mundial de alimentos obtuvo el año
pasado el premio nobel de la paz cómo
piensa usted tratar el tema del hambre
en el continente latinoamericano durante
el mandato que está iniciando para
américa latina es muy importante
participar en el programa mundial de
alimentos porque nosotros somos una
región bastante vulnerable una de las
primeras causas de hambre en el mundo es
la pobreza y esto pues obviamente causa
inseguridad alimentaria entonces mi
función como presidente de la junta
ejecutiva es
también representar a los grupos de
américa latina y el caribe y tratar de
visibilizar estos problemas de nuestra
región no solamente con el programa de
alimentos sino con las demás agencias
del sistema naciones unidas cuando ha
sido el impacto de la pandemia en la
crisis de seguridad alimentaria que
afecta a varias zonas de américa latina
es devastador
realmente américa latina ha sido una de
las regiones más golpeadas por la
pandemia según estimaciones del mismo
programa mundial de alimentos es
probable que se duplique el número de
gente en pobreza en américa latina y
obviamente como dije anteriormente la
pobreza es causa de su demanda
alimentaria y esto necesitaría ya de una
respuesta mucho más coordinada y
acertada del programa de alimentos para
crear una respuesta adecuada
usted es guatemalteco un estudio
gubernamental estima que unas 6.7
millones de personas en guatemala es
decir más o menos el 40% de la población
afronta situaciones de inseguridad
alimentaria cuáles son los factores que
explican esta situación y cómo
combatirlos
uno de los primeros factores que han
incidido en la historia alimentaria
guatemala es el cambio climático el
fenómeno al niño ha ido perdurando mucho
en el tiempo y ha ocasionado que las
sequías sean más largas más duraderas en
guatemala y algunas regiones de
centroamérica y también al mismo tiempo
ocasiona inundaciones en la época
lluviosa lo cual ha destruido y ha
degradado el medio ambiente el programa
mundial de alimentos y otras agencias
del sistema de naciones unidas trabajan
en resiliencia en ayudar al gobierno a
crear capacidades para que estas crisis
pueden ser prevenibles o sin casos
suceden que las crisis puedan ser
atendidas de manera inmediata cuáles son
las iniciativas del programa mundial de
alimentos para luchar contra el hambre
en venezuela tienen efecto el programa
de alimentos ha hecho misiones de
evaluación sobre la situación de
seguridad alimentaria en venezuela y
pues lógicamente el programa mundial de
alimentos no puede entrar a los países
siempre la invitación es un tema de
soberanía en el cual el programa mundial
de alimentos respeta plenamente
y si el gobierno de venezuela así lo
desea e invita al programa de alimentos
a tener una actuación un poco más
dirigida hacia los problemas de insegura
alimentaria yo creo que se puede hacer
se estima que el hambre en américa
latina y en el caribe podría afectar a
unas 67 millones de personas de aquí al
año 2030 como generar conciencia en los
gobiernos latinoamericanos para que
actúen en favor de la equidad y contra
las desigualdades sociales para combatir
este flagelo bueno yo creo que uno de
los grandes retos en américa latina es
precisamente luchar contra la
desigualdad yo creo que los gobiernos ya
están trabajando en general cuando
hablamos de los objetivos de desarrollo
sostenible que evidentemente luchan por
alcanzar no solamente el fin al hambre a
la desnutrición pero también encontrar
esa
igualdad que es tanto que tanto los
países estamos ampliando
tanto la situación de postconflicto en
colombia a la población del país en lo
que concierne la seguridad alimentaria
pero yo creo que colombia es un país
bastante resiliente en efecto que seas
uno de los países que ha atendido a más
refugiados de venezuela nosotros creemos
que con la ayuda del programa de
alimentos y con la asistencia del
gobierno colombiano se pueden hacer
frente a estas situaciones de manera más
coordinada mil gracias a embajador luis
carranza por su tiempo y su
disponibilidad y a ustedes televidentes
gracias por continuar con nosotros aquí
en france 24
[Música]